قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل يعتبرون تاجيل
التعديلات القضائيه مناوره
ويؤكدون البقاء في الشارع
اوكرانيا تتسلم دبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه
هو وزير الدفاع يؤكد الاستعداد لهجوم
الربيع
الولايات المتحده تفتح تحقيقا ضد اكبر
منصه في العالم لتداول العملات المشفره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلنا
قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل استمرارهم في
الاحتجاج رغم خطابي رئيس الوزراء بني مي
نتنياهو الذي اعلن فيه تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه وقال قاده الاحتجاجات انها
نتنياهو يناوروا بتاجيل التعديلات من اجل
تمريرها لاحقا بعد اضعاف الضغط الشعبي
مشددين على انهم لن يبتلعوا الطعم في
المقابل اكد اتحاد العمال الاسرائيلي انه
علق الاضراب العام المعلن اليوم
هذا واندلعت شبكات عنيفه بين الشرطه
الاسرائيليه والمحتجين اليمنيين الرافدين
لتعليق الاصلاحات القضائيه وقالت وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه ان الشرطه في تل ابيب
فرقت بين المؤيدين والمعارضين لتعليق
الاصلاحات القضائيه في اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه بريجانس طالبا
بابقاء وزير الدفاع في منصبه وذلك بعد ان
رحبت احزاب المعرض بقرنه يهود تعليق
الاصلاحات القضائيه فقره احزاب المعارضه
انها ستعمل التوصل الاتفاق اذا كانت
الحكومه صادقه واعتبر رئيس الوزراء السابق
ان المعارضه بحاجه للتاكد من ان نتنياهو
لا يمارس الحيل او الخداع وفق تعبيره
واضاف بانه اذا انخرطت الحكومه في حوار
حقيقي وعادل يمكن حينها الخروج من الاسماء
ورغم قرار نتنياهو تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه قال وزير الامن القوميه
الاسرائيلي اثمار بنك كثير ان التعليق
مؤقت من كثير اضافه في تصريحات وسطان صارت
بان نتنياهو وعده بان يتم تمرير التعديلات
خلال شهر من الان مشيرا الى انه بحلول ذلك
الوقت لن تكون هناك حلول وسط وانه سيتم
تنفيذ اراده الاغلبيه
[موسيقى]
في ردود الفعل الخارجيه رحب وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه
بقرار تعليقي تشريع الاصلاح القضائي في
اسرائيل وحثك لجميع الاطراف على ايجاد
ارضيه مشتركه والسعي الى حل طويل الامد
لهذه المشكله الحساسه وفق تعبيره من
جانبها قالت الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها تتابع
بقلق التطورات المتعلقه بمشروع الاصلاح
القضائي في اسرائيل مشيره الى ضروره
التمسك العميق بالمبادئ الديمقراطيه التي
تشكل اساس الصداقه بين البلدين حسب
الخارجيه الفرنسيه وضعت باريس القاده
السياسيين الاسرائيليين الى الامتناع عن
اي عمل او اعلاني من شانه ان يؤدي الى
تفاقم الازمه
اكدت متحدثه باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه انا بلادها تسلم الدبابات
تشالنجر البريطانيه دون ان تحدد عددها
فقالت المتحدثه
البريطانيه باتت موجوده في اوكرانيا لكنها
لم تعطي مزيد من التفاصيل بدوره اكد وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
ان الدبابات البريطانيه ومدرعات سترايكر
الامريكيه وماردر الالمانيه اضيفت الى
الوحدات الاوكرانيه ومن المتوقع مشاركتها
في اي هجوم معاكس تشنه اوكرانيا في الربيع
وبشان التدريبات العسكريه قال وزير الدفاع
البريطاني ان الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين
كانوا يتدربون على استخدام دبابات تشالنجر
اتم مهمهم وبت جاهزين للانتشار على جبهات
القتال كما اكد ولص وصلت وقوف لندن الى
الجانب الجيش الاوكراني وبذل كل ما في
وسها لدعم اوكرانيا مهما استغرق الامر
مسلسل الالمانيه بلاده سلم الثماني عشره
دبابه من طرازلي وبارد اثنان الى اوكرانيا
وتستعد للتسليم المزيد من الدبابات
والمعدات العسكريه التي من شانها دعم
الجيش الاوكراني في المرحله المقبله
قامت المانيا وهولندا بشكل مشترك بتسليم
داخله ومركبات قتال مصفحه للجنود الاوكران
وتستعدان حاليا جنبا الى جنب مع الدنمارك
لتسليم دبابات القتال الرئيسيه
اليوباردوان بالاضافه الى كل المعدات
العسكريه التي من شانها دعم القوات
الاوكرانيه لقد قمنا بتسليم دبابات من
طراز كما اعلن سابقا
تستمر المعارك في شرق اوكرانيا بين طرف
اسرائيل ففي الوقت الذي تصاعد القوات
الروسيه من قصفها لمدينه اف ديفيكا سعيا
للسيطره عليها بدات السلطات الاوكرانيه
باجلاء موظفيها من المدينه
مشاهد الدمار والخراب توحي بان الصور من
فيلم سينمائي عن نهايه العالم لكن الحال
يؤكد انه من واقع بوابه اقليم دونيتس
كالصناعي في الجزء الجنوبي من ضخمه الحديث
هنا عن التي تشهد قصفا مدفعيا مكثفا
السيطره على المدينه الواقعه على مسافه 13
كيلومترا فقط عن دوناتسك تتيح للجيش
الروسي قطع خط امداد القوه الاوكرانيه في
الشرق وسيسمح لموسكو باحكام قبضتها في
جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا وضمان تامين خطوط
امداد لوجيستيه للجيش ومع اشتداد المعارك
السلطات الاوكرانيه بدات في سحب موظفي
البلديه من المدينه الجيش الاوكراني يحاول
التمسك بالمواقع الحاليه وصد الهجمات
الروسيه لحين تزويد تلك الجبهه في السلاح
خبراء روس يصفون استراتيجيه كياب وحلفائها
لمحاوله ارهاق واستنزاف روسيا في الجبهه
الشرقيه بالفاشله فالجيش الروسي يسيطر على
اكثر من 60% من مساحه بخموت وتحديدا القسم
الشرقي الشرقي نهر بخموتكي اضافه الى
الاحياء الجنوبيه والشماليه وكل الطرق
الواصله الى بخمو تحت السيطره الروسيه
باستثناء طريق واحد للسماح بخروج الجيش
الاوكراني وفي حال سقطت ضخمه بالكامل
وسيطره موسكو على افدي افكا فان هذا سيسمح
للروس بتنفيذ تقدم عسكري بوتيره سريعه
وعلى مساحات واسعه وسقوط المدن الكبرى في
دونتسك وفق خبراء عسكريين
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان البحريه
اطلقت صواريخ فرد صوتيه مضاده للسفن على
هدف وهمي في مياه بحر اليابان اضافت بان
صاروخان من نوع موسكت كروز اصابا الهدف
الذي يقع على مسافه حوالي 100 كم بنجاح
وبضربه مباشره
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
البنك الدولي يمنح
ملايين دولار لليمن لمواجهه انعدام الامن
الغذائي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تداعيات التوقيتين في
لبنان السياسيه والطائفيه دفعت برئيس
الحكومه نجيب ميقاطي الى التراجع عن قراره
بالابقاء على التوقيت الشتوي واعلن
الانتقال الى التوقيت الصيفي ليل الاربعاء
الخميس وحتى تعديله يعيش اللبنانيون ضياعا
في امور حياتهم اليوميه
بين التوقيتين في لبنان ضاعت مواعيد
واختلطت اخرى وامتزجت المشاعر بين الغضب
والسخريه من ازمه عقارب ساعه تحدث العالم
بغرابتها
ناجي واحد من الشباب اللبناني الغاضب من
سلطه افتعال الازمات التي لا تؤثر الا على
شعبها
يلا الصراحه اثر علي كثير متشكر الكتير
يعني مؤذي اذا بدك يعني انا كنت هلا مفروض
عند حكيم اسنانكم من ساعه انا هلا فليت من
الشغل راح علي الموعد صار لي اسبوعين بس
بركض ورا هالموعد ليزبطوا ولهلا لظبطنا من
ورا هالتوقيت راحة
على اي توقيت انت سؤال يرافق اللبنانيين
في خطواتهم اليوميه كما حصل في بدايه ازمه
الدولار وانتشار مواقع والتطبيقات تنشر
اسعار الصرف المختلفه باتا للتوقيت في
لبنان موقع ايضا قديش الساعه هو احد هذه
المواقع وعندما ندخل نرى هذين التوقيتين
انترناشونال من بيروت اي التوقيت العالمي
في بيروت
اي بالريميقات تايم وفي البدايه هناك
اشاره وبطريقه فكاهيه الى ان هذا التوقيت
هو حسب سوق التوقيت بدل السوق السوداء
حالات الضياع انسحبت على المؤسسات
والمدارس والمصارف بين من بقي على التوقيت
الشتوي ومن غيره الى الصيفي على انعم
مدرسه الجديد يعني الصيفه الشرعي ولاده
الشتوي فبكره بالعاده انا واولادي
يعني ما ضايعه مش عارفين كيف بدنا نمشي
استغلت ازمه التوقيت لتصفيه الحسابات
السياسيه ونبشت قبور الطائفيه ما دفع
برئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي
وبعد اجتماع الحكومه الى اعلان العوده الى
التوقيت الصيفي ليلى الاربعاء الخميس بعد
معالجه الامور التقنيه ناهد يوسف العربيه
بيروت
اعلن ان باسم وزاره الداخليه الافغانيه
عبد النافع تكور مقتله سته مدنيين على
الاقل في هجوم الانتحاري بكابل تبناه
تنظيم داعش في وقت لاحق واوضحت هكر ان
القوات الافغانيه استهدفت المهاجم امام
مركز تجاري قربه وزاره الخارجيه لكن الاب
التي كان يحملها انفجرت ما اسفر عن مقتدى
سته مدنيين واصابه اخرين
قالت مديره مكتب البنك الدولي في اليمن
تعني امير ان البنك وافق على تمويل اضافي
بقيمه 207 ملايين دولار لليمن بهدف التصدي
لمشكلتي انعدام الامن الغذائي وسوء
التغذيه المزمنتين قالت مير ان التمويل
الجديد سيساعد على استدامه المشروع الطارئ
لتعزيز الحمايه الاجتماعيه والاستجابه
لجائحه كورونا في اليمن وتوسيع نطاقات
واضافت انه من المتوقع ان تستفيد حوالي
مليون
و800 الف اسره يمنيه من التمويل الاضافي
الجديد واكدت مير ان هذا التمويل الاضافي
يعكس التزام البنك الدولي الراسخ
بالارتقاء بمستوى حياه اليمنيين الذين
وقعوا في خضم ازمات متعدده
في تعز تصاعد الميليشيات الحثيه من
عملياتها العسكريه ما يزيد المخاوف من نسف
جهود السلام الامويه الميليشيات الحوثيه
تعمل على استهداف الاحياء السكنيه
والاهداف المدنيه بالطائرات المسيره
والقذائف كما تمارس انتهاكات جسيمه بحق
المدنيين التفاصيل في تقرير هايل سعيد
اتجهت ميليشيات الحوثي لتصعيد عسكريا في
تعز باستخدام مسيراتها ما يزيد المخاوف من
نصف جهود السلام الامميه المطروحه على
طاوله التفاوض فاستهدفها موكب محافظه تعز
ونقاطا امنيه واحياء مدنيه بمسيارات مفخخه
اعطى اشارات عن تفضيل الميليشيات للخيار
العسكري
الانقلابيه تركز في تصعيدها على جبهات
مارب وقفات التعجب باتجاه
الكريش وباتجاهها الضالع
وبكل متابعين لموقف والتحركات التي تقوم
بهذه الامريكيات لكنها هي اضعف من اي وقت
مضى اعتقد ان محاوله الهدف منها
بشارع المساعي التي تقري حاليا من اجل
الدخول في تسويه السياسيه او على الاقل
التمهيد السويس السياسيه
وكما نعلم ان الميليشيات هي غير راضيه عن
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني وهي تشعر بان
هذا يعني موافقت على هذا الاتفاق وشجعته
على مضاد من اجل عدم خساره حليب اهل
الايراني وهي الان تريد ان تحاول تغيير
الصراع باي صوره من اجل هذا الاتفاق
والعوده الى المربع الاول هذا التصعيد
الحوثي في تعز اعتبرته الحكومه اليمنيه
عملا ارهابيا يؤكد رفض الحوثيين صراحه
لجهود السلام واكده في الوقت ذاته انها لن
تقف مكتفه الايدي امام تماد الميليشيات
ومساعيها في اطاله امد الحرب وتعميق
الماساه الانسانيه في البلد
مؤخره قامت جماعه الحوث في محافظه تعز
باستداف الاطفال سواء في احياء كلابه هناك
العشرات خلال
2023 تم استهدافهم للابطال والنساء من
خلال هذه الجماعه
كلما شددت كل ما اشتدت الجبهات تتعمد
جماعات الحوثي في استهداف المدني كضغط على
الحكومه الشرعيه بايقاف اي اي هجوم او اي
صادق لهجمه هذه الجماعه الى جانب تلك
تؤجج الميليشيات الحوثيه الوضع العسكري في
جبهه القتال حيث تشن هجمات على مواقع
للقوات الحكوميه في الجبهات الشرقيه
والغربيه من تعز بالطيران المسير ومختلف
انواع الاسلحه بالاضافه الى استخدامها
تعزيزات عسكريه من محافظتي ابوذمار الى
اطراف المدينه لن تتوقف الميليشيات
الحوثيه عند هذا الحد من التصعيد العسكري
وحسبه بل مارسات انتهاكات الجسيمه بحق
مئات المدنيين باستهدافهم بالقنص والقصف
المدفعي الى الاحياء السكنيه محدثه قتلى
وجرحى في صفوفهم هل سعيد العربيه تعز
بعد سنوات من اهمال السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه لمنطقه الساحه الغرب افريقيا
عدت اداره بايدن خطه تمتد لعشر سنوات لمنع
الصراع وتعزيز الاستقرار في ليبيا وقدمتها
الكونجرس وذلك بموجب خطه امريكيه تهدف
لتحقيق الاستقرار بالمناطق المتضرره من
الصراعي في العالم
مصادر طاقه لا تنضب واراضي شاسعه ينعم
فيها خصوم واشنطن بالحريه
ليبيا البلد الذي يختزل كل اطماع الدول
تغيب فيه سفاره امريكيه عقود مرت وسياسه
واشنطن لا تزال تدير ظهرها لافريقيا ولن
تكفي الاراده السياسيه والخطابات لعودتها
الواقع شيء اخر
القاره اصابتها عدوى الاقتصاد الصيني
ومتلازمه فاجنر التي ارهقت فرنسا في مناطق
نفوذها التاريخيه عوده واشنطن تحتاج الى
خطه والكثير من الوقت
عشر سنوات كامله ستمضيها واشنطن في اعاده
ترتيب خريطه النفوذ حسب اهوائها البدايه
من ليبيا ثم موزمبيق وغينيا الجديده وفي
غرب القاره وقع الخيار على بنين وكوت
ديفوار وغانا
اداره بايدن حددت ليبيا لتكون بوابه
العوده وهي التي اغلق دبلوماسيوها سفارتهم
فيها قبل عشر سنوات
النيه الان موجوده لكن التنفيذ تحد اخر لا
يمكنني اعطاء جدول زمني لكننا نعمل على
اعاده فتح سفاراتنا في ليبيا بنشاط وانا
مثلك تماما اطمحوا لاعاده تاسيس وجود
مستمر لنا في ليبيا ماذا عن تفاصيل الخطه
اولا دعم الشعب الليبي حتى يتمكن من
ممارسه حقه في انتخاب ممثليه وفي سبيل ذلك
كل اساليب الضغط الامريكيه مباحه قياده
وجيش واحد لبلد موحد لكن الجهود في
البدايه استفردت بالجنوب الليبي وهو
النقطه المحوريه في الخطه
وفقط بعد ظهور النتائج تعمم التجربه على
بقيه مناطق البلاد ومنها دول الساحل وغرب
افريقيا
المشروع استفاد من دعم الحزبين ومن خلاله
تعتزم امريكا بناء وجود دائم وقوي في
افريقيا
المبادره رفعت شعار حل الازمه الليبيه
لكنها قد تخفي اطماعا في خيرات البلاد او
حتى صراع نفوذ لا ينقص اراضي ليبيا الا ان
تحتضن احد فصوله
اتهمت السلطات الامريكيه المنصه العملاقه
لتداول العملات المشفره باينانس بارتكاب
بممارسات غير قانونيه واكدت لجنه تداول
السلع الاجله الامريكيه ان التهم الموجهه
الى باينانس تعد جزءا من حمله لوقف سوء
السلوكي في سوق الاصول الرقميه المتقلبه
والمحفوفه بالمخاطر
اثارت الجلسه التي ادلى فيها الرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك بشهادته امام لجا مجلس
النواب للطاقه والتجاره في الكونجرس حول
مخاوف شان تهديدات الامن القومي المحتمله
للتطبيق الشعبي وعلاقته بالصين اثارت موجه
سخريه من قبل مستخدمي تيك توك والامريكيين
بشكل عام
بعد الجلسه الشهيره في الكونجرس للرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك امام لجنه مجلس النواب
للطاقه والتجاره اعتبر العديد من مستخدمي
تيك توك ان اعضاء الكونجرس لا يعرفون كيف
تعمل التكنولوجيا ومنفصلون عن العصر
الحديث
الاسئله التي وجهت الى تيوب كانت عنيفه
وجعلت الرئيس الشاب عاجزا عن الاجابه في
كثير من الاحيان لا لعدم امتلاكه الاجوبه
الشافيه ولكن لصعوبه فهم الكثير من النقاط
التي طرحت كما حصل هنا لنسمع سؤال ان
هل باستطاع التيك توك الدخول على شبكه
الواي فاي الخاصه بمنزلي
عذرا لم افهم السؤال
تيك توك الدخول على شبكه الواي فاي الخاصه
بمنزلي
اما اجابه احد المستخدمين فكانت هذا سخيف
اسئله ممثل الامه الامريكيه اثارت موجه
كبيره من السخريه لدى الشباب على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه مستخدمي تيك توك
الذين اعتبروا انها دليل على استهداف
التطبيق الشهري بعينه تيك توك لا يختلف
ابدا عن منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الاخرى مثل فيسبوك وتويتر وانستجرام وفي
الحقيقه فان مشروع تكساس الذي يطرح الان
من قبل تيك توك مهم للغايه ولكن المخاوف
من امكانيه اختراق الحكومه الصينيه
للحسابات الامريكيه قائمه دائما جمع
الحزبين الرئيسيين في جبهه واحده تماما
كما فعل
ولكن في المقابل نظم بعض النواب من مناهضي
حظر التطبيق وقفه احتجاجيه مخالفه تماما
لما رايناه داخل الجلسه وهذا النائب
الامريكي شمال بومن يقول
التعديل الاول يقفل لنا حريه التعبير
وبحضر تيك توك نحن نخالف هذا الحق ونحن
نمنع منصه جمعتنا وساعدتنا على النمو
باعمالنا الى مستوى اخر ان حظر تيك توك
سخيف
وامام هذا الكم الهائل من التعليقات على
الجلسه الشهيره اعتبرت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز انس نقلت الى واشنطن اكثر من 30
مؤثرا على المنصه للدفاع عن التطبيق بعد
جلسه الاستماع
العربيه واشنطن
في اسكتلندا فاز سكرتير مجلس الوزراء
للعدد حمزه يوسف بزعامه الحزب الوطني
الاسكتلندي ومن المتوقع ان يخلف يوسف
نيكولاسيرا اول لسكتلندا اثرى تصويت سيتم
اليوم في البرلمان اسكتلندي في ادنبرا
[تصفيق]
حمزه يوسف اول زعيم اسكتلنديا مسلم بعد
انتخابه زعما للحزب الوطني لاسكتلندي
تمهيدا لخلافه نيكولا المستقيله كوزير
الاول
حمزه يوسف ابن ابوين هجران من باكستان الى
غلاسكو في ستينات القرن الماضي ووصوله الى
اعلى منصب سياسي في اسكتلندا لم يكن صدفه
نظرا للتجاربه السياسيه في عده
مناصبعه في التعامل مباشر مع رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا
ذي الاصل الهندي لمواجهه التحديات البلاد
لا اعتقد انه سيكون هناك اي توتر ملحوظ
بين القائدين على الرغم من انه بالطبع وضع
رائع بالنظر الى تاريخ الامبراطوريه
البريطانيه وهو بالتاكيد شيء يجب الاحتفال
به وشيء مثير للاهتمام وان كان هناك ما
سيقرب القائدين من بعضهما البعض فقد تكون
الخلفيه العرقيه والتجارب المتشابهه في
حياتهما خلال نش اتهما في المملكه المتحده
تعهدات حمزه يوسف بما فيها تحقيق ما فشلت
فيه سلفه بعقد استفتاء لاستقلال اسكتلندا
عن المملكه المتحده والانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيشكل النقطه الخلافيه الكبرى مع
الحكومه في لندن القائدان السوناك وحمزه
في مسار مواجهه شرسه بشان استقلال
اسكتلندا وموقف الحكومه البريطانيه ثابت
لحمايه دول الاتحاد البريطاني
افهم تماما السياق التاريخيه امامنا
واعتقد انه لا توجد اي طبقات اخرى من
الصراع ليست موجوده بالفعل فيما يتعلق
بالقوميه الاسكتلنديه فانه يجب الاحتفال
بالتنوع العرقي والتوتر مع حكومه المملكه
المتحده مستمر منذ عقود ولا اعتقد ان هذا
سيكون مختلفا في المستقبل
اقليه عرقيه الان اصبحت تدير شؤون
الاغلبيه من البيض في اسكتلندا وباقي
الاراضي البريطانيه
الزعيم الاسكتلندي حمزه يوسف هو رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني من ابناء مهاجرين قدموا
من مستعمرات الامبراطوريه البريطانيه
السابقه وصولهما الى اعلى المناصب
السياسيه يعكس نجاح نموذج الاندماج في بلد
كان يحكم ارض اجدادهما مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن